The way to avoid stupid choices in the algorithm and actually we can make Alice
a little bit more happy because we're soon going to show her that we're not going to make her
totally happy but at least neutral because we're now going to show her
a better technique than brute force.
And that better technique is known as a search tree and you would soon see why it's called a tree.
If you were solving vertex cover by yourself, you would probably take the following approach.
You would not see for all vertices together if they are in the vertex cover or not
but rather you would look at a single vertex, say this one here, and then split it into two possibilities.
One, you're going to say, "Yes, let's make this vertex part of the vertex cover."
And the other one, you would say, "No, I do not want this vertex to be part of the vertex cover."
And then, you're going to split down further so on this side here and on this side here.
Let's look at this vertex here next.
We're just going to draw it a little bit smaller so that we don't run out of space.
We already know that this vertex here is in the vertex cover
and we're now deciding for this vertex here on the left.
So we'll have one case where we do put it into the vertex cover and another one where
we don't put it into the vertex cover.
And then for each of these cases again we can split into two possibilities.
And this time we're going to look at the vertex down here. Same here.
One case where we put it into the vertex cover and another case where we don't.
Now here for this case already, we can stop. We have found a solution of size 3.
All edges are covered. We do not even need to consider the possibilities for this vertex here.
Over here, we still have to consider two possibilities so we still need to make a decision
here on the right side so we can either put it into the vertex cover or not put it into the vertex cover.
And so this solution here or it's not solution because it's not valid.
And here again we have found a solution of size 3 or a vertex cover of size 3.
So I'm just going to leave this check mark here and have this account for both.
So now we still have to continue here for these four points where we left off earlier
and again we're going to do the same thing so we're going to consider one possibility where
this vertex down here is not in the vertex cover and again we see.
Oops! This is invalid so we do not need to continue any further.
The next time we're going to put this vertex into the vertex cover.
And yes, we have a valid solution of size 2.
Continuing over here. We're going to consider this vertex here again.
So one possibility would be to not put it into the vertex cover but that is already invalid.
And another one would be to put it into the vertex cover, which again leads us to further
possibilities to check and we're going to check them for this one down here.
So same game. Invalid solution over here. Still valid over here.
And we need to consider two more cases.
And you already know that this case here is going to be invalid.
And over here we're finding a solution of size 3. So that's all that.
Originally, we had with brute force 16 assignments of 0 and 1 to the vertices that we needed to check
and now this algorithm here only considered 9 assignments.
So I told you at the beginning of this course that constant factor speedups
probably don't matter that much when we're dealing with exponential time algorithms.
So we will have to do some further analysis on this one.
And you also noticed that there could be certain other techniques that we can use for speedups.
So for example here, we had already found a solution of size 2.
So we probably could've even stopped our algorithm a little bit earlier
over here but we're going to get into this.
The main thing that I would like you to understand is the technique of the search tree
and we're now going to analyze this search tree further and try to improve it.
And of course, I should also tell you why it is called a search tree.
And to show you this, draw lines along where the algorithm was searching
and then we're going to rotate this picture by 180 degrees and now here you can see
a beautiful tree with the solution as the leaves or the fruit or whatever you will.
But this is why it's called a search tree.
It's basically a tree that hangs upside down.
I don't know what the terminology tells you about computer scientists
but that's not my concern here.